un président au plus près de la ligne de
front lors d'une de ses rares sorties
volodymyr zelensky s'entretient avec les
militaires ukrainien dans le dôme basse
l'endroit exact est tenu secret pour des
raisons de sécurité dernière avancée
évaluation des pertes des deux côtés le
chef de l'état mué en chef de guerre a
visité plusieurs villes de la région
pour redonner un peu d'espoir à sa
population
nous sommes allés à l'est avec le chef
de cabinet nous étions à l'issue de
chance à sol et d'arrêt je suis fier de
chaque personne que j'ai rencontrée de
tous ceux à qui j'ai serré la main avec
qui j'ai discuté et que j'ai encouragé
nous avons apporté quelque chose à
l'armée on parlerait pas en détail nous
vous avons aussi ramener quelque chose
de leur part et c'est important nous
vous avons ramené de la confiance et de
la force
à quelques kilomètres de là la ville de
severodonezk huillo rythme quotidien des
bombardements russes depuis plusieurs
jours sa prise est un objectif militaire
stratégique pour moscou qui veut
contrôler toute la région du donbass un
objectif qui serait aujourd'hui
compromis par la résistance ukrainienne
les russes contrôler 70% de la ville
mais lors des dernières 48 heures nous
avons réussi à les repousser
la ville est désormais pratiquement
coupée en deux les russes ont même peur
de se déplacer dans la ville
une information impossible à vérifier
tant la situation évolue au fil des
jours seule certitude les combats de rue
sont de plus en plus féroce chaque camp
des pleurs des pertes considérables dans
ces unités
voilà pour la situer